yeah hello I don't know if this is
actually working but I want to try I
just want to give you a quick update on
the the channel at the moment I'm
currently on vacation and I'm just using
my little camera here to give you a
brief impression about the view from my
hotel room Oh actually it's not the
hotel room but I'm staying outside here
it's beautiful beautiful weather here
it's like 33 34 degrees in Celsius of
course it's very sunny get a nice view
here with them the hills and mountains
far away I think from the direction not
quite sure which direction I'm looking
at the moment it's near the creation
border and yeah very nice very nice yeah
so am I try to to make a video earlier
just video and they didn't really work
out I've got the internet connection but
the old said I was simply too slow to
make a decent blitz video I'll try to to
change some settings but not quite sure
that that it's actually working I try to
do some updates though on the olympiad
later I mean later meaning us on monday
and the days after monday we caught the
tournament starts there I should have
the opportunity to do this it doesn't
really rely so much on the connection
quality yeah I'm enjoying my holiday and
I wish all of you at least a nice
weekend so cheers and take care